I want to preface this by saying that
I'm not Muslim I'm Jewish by the way if
you are Muslim I hope I'm not being
disrespectful this is just my experience
in reading the Quran for the first time
asalam greetings of Peace what I'm about
to show you next is truly unbelievable
but I've noticed something and I'm sure
a lot of Muslims have also noticed this
that through you know this entire thing
with Palestine so many more people are
learning about Islam and so many more
people are reading the Quran I read the
Quran I love the Quran I think it's a
beautiful piece of text I think that
it's wonderful and it has so much
incredible history in it just like so
many different spiritual texts and
religious texts but like it just makes
me laugh y'all are about to get a lot of
converts y'all call them reverts though
right that's really interesting like
reverting to
Islam that's really interesting that's
an interesting concept to me y you got
have a lot of people turning to Islam
soon I've seen people be like wow this
is really interesting H honey you're
next what I'm about to show you next is
truly unbelievable but from the other
side of things things that maybe you
didn't think about with all the sadness
that we're seeing on the flip side Allah
is the best of planners we got people
saying that what's happening now is
another Holocaust and they're saying
alhamdulillah and quotes like I haven't
seen any footage of them even cursing
Jews another person said these people
are people of God another the lady was
shocked to the core seeing the faith of
Muslims these are just some of the
quotes let's go ahead and get into this
video and I'll get you a free gift on
what they're talking about after we come
back 100% feel comfortable saying that
what's happening now to the Palestinian
people is another Holocaust and they're
still saying
alhamdulillah say known that
alhamdulillah alul Muslim Palestinians
still seeing them saying Allah is all
knowing
Palestinians are doing everything that
was described job doing in the
Bible I've have not seen any footage of
Palestinian people cursing Jewish people
or Israeli people these are people of
God I know these people were blessed by
Allah himself hold faith
is with such an indominable hope they
don't give up about this life okay the
only thing these people fear is
Allah that's it if this is the campaign
to to get Nations to be Islamic it's
doing it I've been shocked to my core at
the faith Muslim people have what is
happening in Palestine has opened my
eyes to the beauty of Islam that's
something that people don't get to see
often definitely not here in the west
into the Bible asking logical questions
were not allowed when I read through the
Quran I see logic and Divinity brought
together result of that is on social
media I have seen so many
people picking up the Quran and reading
it through you know this entire thing
with Palestine so many more people are
learning about Islam so many more people
are reading the Quran you got to have a
lot of people turning to Islam soon it's
happening again it's like all these
people I see Quan B Club I see people
deciding to convert to Islam because
they're like well what what is really
going on here I just bought my first
copy of the Quran I got the Quran I
started reading the Quran it's my day
two in reading the Quran I gotop how
these
Palestinians literally are thanking God
seeing the
brave Palestine people as they're losing
everything so much faith and peace
while their families are being murdered
States we need a lot more empathy and
understanding of Muslims in the Arab
world I need to know what y'all foot in
Islam okay I just from reading the
second surra I'm like I get it I
understand why there's such a steadfast
Faith to anyone that follows Islam being
shown just how wrong we were about this
faith and how rich how like how deep and
just the language of it how fluid and
beautiful it is we've been lied to the
Western people and I took my shahada I
feel tremendous peace and I'm going to
be reading it forever wow that is just
truly amazing you wouldn't think about
that huh Allah is they PL plan Allah
plans Allah God Almighty is the best of
planners so we're seeing the flip side
of things some things maybe you didn't
even think about and yes we pray for
those innocent human beings innocent
souls and inshallah Allah while we're
crying for them inshallah they God
willing will be rejoicing inshallah in
Jenna we have to be positive even at
times like this because they're being
positive at times like this and what
about us what do we have to cry for
compared to what they're going through
it's a great reflection for us to to
really count the blessings that we have
to really be thankful if they're able to
thank God Almighty Allah in those dire
situations what about us what excuses do
we have are we making Salah are we
connecting with our creator and Salah
minimum five times a day are we adhering
to how Allah wants us to God Almighty
the Creator wants us to live are we just
stuck nagging and complaining not
satisfied with all the abundance of
things that we have in this life and it
gives us a lot a lot to unpackage and to
think about and you see that people at
this in these moment D moments it's
impressing that not yet Muslims out
there they're seeing like wow so earlier
today I made a video saying how
impressed I was with Palestinian Faith
because it just seems that Palestinians
have this
Ironclad Faith even in the face of
losing quite literally everything and
people were commenting underneath saying
well yeah girl that's Islam have you
read the Quran you should probably read
the Quran and I have time and I was also
curious as to what how how even in at
facing genocide is Palestinian faith so
strong and so I decided to go on scrip
to see if there was an audiobook version
of the Quan there is and so I started
listening straight off the bat what I'm
a fan
of there is no introduction I even
thought that I I accidentally skipped
over something because it gets straight
to it like there is no once upon a time
there is no in the beginning there is
none of that it was like all right if
you do this then this happens if you do
this like it gets straight into it and
by the way if you are Muslim I hope I'm
not being disrespectful this is just my
experience in reading the Quran for the
first time I'm on I'm on like chapter
four of like 117 but I found some things
very interesting like first it
said oppression is worse than murder and
I was like that's a word and then it was
saying um it was talking about divorce
and I didn't know divorce was allowed
divorce is allowed in the Islamic
religion or Islam religion
and it was saying how if you're a woman
and you get divorced you have to wait
three periods I don't know how long a
period is but you have to wait three
periods and then you okay to remarry
girl like go find your husband and it
was saying if you're a dude and you
divorce your wife and you haven't
touched her yet but you promised her a
DA you still got to pay half that [__] I
was like feminism and then there was um
a part in there that I was surprised
about I don't know why I thought it was
going to be like the Christian religion
where um if somebody slaps you you got
to offer your other cheek and and
everything because that always bothered
me like I'm like if I if somebody slaps
me I should be able to slap them back in
the Quran it says if somebody fights you
you fight them back like if whatever
they do to you you do to them and I was
like
absolutely so far it's been a time with
bombs flaing all around them they're
losing family members and their children
their loved ones and they're still
thanking God Almighty and they're saying
these are people of God these are these
are signs for them and they're coming to
Islam now you see these people these are
only the people that these are just the
people that we're seeing imagine how
many are out there they're they're
they're not on camera how many people
are being affected through this and
they're actually looking into the Quran
and that's the gift that I want to give
you if you believe Now by by seeing this
and you go ahead and take the step to
see like even more like what is the
fundamental belief of Islam and Islam
means submission to the will of the
creator of the heavens and earth and
that's how you get true purpose and
peace in life by submitting to the one
who created you God Almighty the creator
of Allah he sent Messengers through time
and they came came with the same message
that message wasn't different different
contentor religions it was always the
same that concept of submitting your
will to the one and only creator of the
heavens and earth not to a human being
not to an angel not to your ideas not to
money not to fame not to your ego but to
the one who created you the one that
Jesus prayed to the one that Moses
prayed to the one that they called human
beings to submit to and Prophet Muhammad
was just the last and final messenger
sent to mankind so Islam is built on
that pure monotheism of only worshiping
the Creator and not his creation if you
can dig that everything else God willing
will fall into place so while we're
crying while we're sad for the departure
of our brothers and sisters there Allah
is the most wise Allah is the most just
they're inshallah seeing the other side
and they're rejoicing in joy and we make
Dua that we can Unite with our brothers
and sisters our loved ones in Jenna now
with that said I promised you a gift you
can go ahead and go to the Deen show.com
to get your free copy of the Quran this
is what you're you're seeing that is
having them the people in Palestine the
people who have bombs dropping on their
houses left and right and Center all
over the place and they're still finding
that resilience that faith is strong
it's because of this this book the Quran
and if you go to the Deens show.com free
if you're in the United States and I
believe in Canada we can go ahead and
ship this to you for free thank you very
much I thought this is amazing wanted to
share with you don't forget to subscribe
so you don't miss any videos that we put
out if you benefited hit the
notification Bell share like and we'll
see you next time until then peace be
with you allum this guy right here this
guy's trying to build a DA Center in our
country I'm not talking to you right now
you're a c you're trying to build a daa
center here Islam is violent by Nature
asalam brothers and sisters this is
exactly why we need the dean Center
because we have over 300 million
Americans who know nothing about Islam
like this guyy you want to have a talk
yeah this guy's trying to build a DA
Center in our country Surah 9 is the
most violent chapter of the Quran the
dean Center will be a source of light a
mega dawa Center an educational center
helping our brothers and sisters in
humanity truly understand Islam and
Muslims and brothers and sisters
remember the great rewards of just
guiding one person in humanity to the
truth is better than everything in this
D so get in on all the rewards and
blessings click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of
[Music]
you